think songwriters are usually
the sort of some of the least celebrated
the ones that stay behind the scenes and
are drawing out most of the
vulnerability from artists so it's
really amazing to see this format of
awards where they're brought to the
front and celebrated I think it's just
like such a treat to see
um and also we're you know technology is
changing we're talking a lot about Ai
and as a songwriter do you feel
threatened by it do you think it's
something you can Embrace how are you
how are you looking at that uh I think
in certain ways it can be embraced I'm
definitely scared yeah I'm definitely a
little threatened by it okay I can't lie